for years general abdulrahman gyani led
a God that protected Ninja's president
Muhammad bazum
is now unseated him and replaced him
the self-appointed leader has dissolved
Ninja's Constitution
in an exclusive interview with Al
Jazeera a presidential advisor says
chiani is jeopardizing more than
politics
so far blood has not been shed but the
statements of the coup leader are
dangerous and can aggravate the
situation more will begin to question
the legality of recruiting hundreds of
soldiers this may lead to an outbreak of
an ethnic conflict the people of Niger
reject the military coup and mostly
support president Muhammad bazum
supporters of General ciani warn any
foreign military intervention will lead
to chaos
the International Community says it's
here for us we don't want them here we
don't want its moral lessons it's no
longer credible in the eyes of Africans
jealous of appointment came after chaos
and demonstrations grouped the capital
Miami after Wednesday's cool
crowds set fire to cars and buildings
near the headquarters of Basil's party
two years into his presidency
demonstrators say the deposed president
didn't do enough Sunday school
I agree with chiani I've spent a lot of
time criticizing the mismanagement of
security and the presence of foreign
forces in our country their presence is
more about diplomacy but it's of little
use
many Western allies disagree
they insist Niger needs military support
from the U.S and France to find the
expansion of armed groups linked to
al-Qaeda in isil
did Germany have a new leader but its
political uncertainty still looms across
the West Africa region
Al Jazeera
Jude Moore is a former Liberian Minister
and is now a senior policy fellow at the
center for Global development he says
it's difficult to assess if Regional
leaders have any leverage over the coup
leaders
you have to remember this is the fourth
in the West Africa region and every
single one of the coup plotters received
a similar ultimatum about restoring a
constitutional order so it's really hard
today if there's some bite behind the
bark and because the continent is under
significant stress there are all kinds
of things happening now the African
union doesn't have a standing army that
they can send in even in West Africa
it's difficult to imagine what they
would do beyond the ultimatum now they
might impose sanctions on them and cut
them off from Trading regionally but
it's really really difficult to know
what the African Union can do beyond the
ultimatum and Julia what about pressure
then from the International Community I
mean France refuses to recognize the new
leaders the EU says look we're going to
suspend financial aid and security
Corporation will this Force the coup
leaders to return to civilian rule will
this pressure work is is unclear if it
will work well because you know even the
United States is actually considering
suspending a substantial economic and
security partnership with with uh
Indonesia however when the West refused
to engage in a situation of a coup it
opens the door of course for other
actors who do not care about the regime
type and in this case especially the
Wagner group and Russia there is a
possibility here that if the United
States France and the European Union
even the West African leaders refuse to
engage the coup plotters that it
provides an opening for France to expect
for Russia and the Wagner group to
explain it yet another country on the
continent